et les réunions s'enchaînent pour les
principaux concernés de l' incendie du
siaap
une nouvelle rencontre s'est tenue cette
fois en préfecture de versailles à huis
clos en présence de la secrétaire d'état
la transition écologique
trois axes de travail une meilleure
information association des riverains
des habitants un travail sur la sécurité
du site avec un audit externe et une
maîtrise du process de reconstruction et
de de qualité des eaux et de limitation
du risque à déverser des eaux dans la
seine et donc avoir de la mortalité
piscicole d'ici à l'été prochain
il y a trois mois un incendie se déclare
et à la station d'épuration d'achères
impliquant une forte pollution de la
senne un audit réclamé dès juillet
débutera à la mi novembre
l'audit doit nous permettent de voir les
choses qu' on n'a pas perçu ou qu'on n'a
pas détecté et qui vont faire le point
sur les faiblesses éventuelles existe il
faudra tout de suite et renforcée par
attendre la fin de l'audit qui elle aura
lieu à la fin du premier trimestre on a
précisé que le siaap avec les étapes
intermédiaires au mois de juin on sera
en capacité d'avoir un fonctionnement
identique à celui de 2016 avant la
livraison d'une nouvelle installation en
2017 une sixième réunion est prévue pour
la mi-décembre en sous-préfecture de
saint-germain-en-laye
une rencontre entre les riverains et la
secrétaire d'état pourrait se tenir
courant novembre